大家好 我是Seyoung
大家好 我是Crystal
現在是
松州的冬天
我們今天最後要去吃飯
我們現在要去找我們另一個朋友了
現在這個大曆光很漂亮
好冷喔 冷到我眼淚都掉下來
但是其實今天蠻冷的
今天現在只有五度而已
然後我們兩個居然只穿了這樣
我裡面是一件胸罩
然後再加一件就是
然後再加一件Marking King的皮外套
然後妳的呢?
我裡面就只有一件短袖
因為我現在沒有什麼衣服可以穿了
我這次來都把衣服穿完了
神經病
然後跟一件皮外
喔 蠻涼的
五度的天氣她裡面穿短袖
神經病
沒辦法 這次沒買什麼東西
就叫妳買衣服了
叫她多買一點
她需要打扮自己
我們剛剛早上用了什麼?
泡泡的 很像Mousse的產品
對 然後它是一個保養品的彩妝
那個形容詞是這樣的
昨天韓國歐尼跟我們說的
然後昨天他就跟我說
如果他說
菜喲啊 保養品的彩妝
他沒有說過你會說
他真的會說
我們昨天用的那個
保養品的那個
保養品的美膏
真的滿好用的
因為早上起來上完妝
就是超級的透
我們剛剛到這間
昨天歐尼推薦給我們的
一個朝日餐廳
然後它就是有
一些鬆餅啊
一些朝日餐盤這樣
感覺
蠻local的
這才是今天的移動
安妞哈嚕
我們哈嚕忙了來了
哈嚕的最後
最後哪裡啊
這個表格是在那邊
謝謝
我吃了一碗
你好
我是Krysta
我是Krysta的頻道
這是我的頻道
我把我的頻道搶走了
從現在開始由我接管
現在太忙了
我可以把手指推直
我們要來逛一個美術館
在漢南棟
就是李泰熱這邊
Contemporary
Oh
This is a contemporary
Contemporary
Oh
Cool
我第一次看到美術館長這樣耶
我剛看完那個展覽了
覺得蠻酷的
這個展覽有很多很酷的地方
就是因為它有多了很多
真人實際上的互動
這個我覺得非常的酷
很像我在紐約看那種
古根漢博物館的感覺
蠻特別的
但是我覺得最特別還是人的互動
就是人的表演
人的表演有非常多種
所以你可以很細微的觀察到
那你們現在聽到的聲音
應該就是那些人在
就是唱歌的聲音
好久沒有來漢南洞了
然後我就發現最近有一些新出的店
然後這個是Rose Jenny同款的衣服
我有在小紅書上面看到的
是新的耶
我的菜耶
這些滿辣的喔
店還有分兩層樓
走比較休閒的路
走比較休閒風格為主的
漂亮
陽光折射進來的美
沒有穿過裙子
這誰啊
我覺得超適合你的
超適合我是嗎
好新穎喔
連我自己都覺得很新穎
美式
Sore真的對我來說算是一個
非常輕鬆然後非常方便的一個地方
可能會講韓文我覺得對我來說還是差蠻多的
就是來首爾旅遊這件事情會讓我覺得說
在語言上面會有一種很有成就感的感覺
就比起如果去歐洲的話要講英文這件事情對我來說比較困難
但是如果講韓文的話就會覺得方便蠻多的
這間呢就是漢南東新開的一間店
然後我也是第一次看到它
忘記是去年年底還是今年開的
然後綜合了很多品牌
的一間店這樣
Martin King到Dipang
到其他的Rotary的牌子都有這樣
這間不錯 蠻好看的
那個單身極地獄的金高恩的pick
然後就發現很多都是他的pick款耶
蠻酷的
我們晚上要去吃烤肉
但實在是太餓了
我等不到那個時候了
就先點了炒年糕 然後魷魚
然後跟一個Sundae 血腸
我要來吃吃看他家的Tteokbokki
我是Tteokbokki愛好者
超愛
哇 很好吃欸